i'm here today to express the nation's
gratitude to justice stephen breyer he
served on the nation's highest court for
more than a quarter century presiding
over some of its most controversial
cases from abortion to the environment
but on thursday u.s president joe biden
announced the 83-year-old supreme court
justice stephen breyer was stepping down
i think he's a model public servant in a
time of great division in this country
breyer was nominated to the court by
democratic president bill clinton in
1994. as he reflected on his years on
the bench breyer concluded the united
states is a complicated nation
it's a kind of miracle
when you sit there and see all those
people in front of you
people that are so different in what
they think
and yet they've decided
to help
solve their major differences
under law breyer plans to step down this
summer when the supreme court completes
its term his replacement biden affirms
will fulfill a campaign pledge to make
history the person i will nominate
will be someone with extraordinary
qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to united states
supreme court
it's long overdue in my view
biden says he's vetting candidates and
will announce his nominee next month one
that won't alter the ideological makeup
of the court that currently leans
conservative but the decision to
nominate a qualified black woman is
deliberate biden's eager to please black
voters whose support he relied on in the
2020 election the timing is no accident
with midterm elections for the u.s
congress coming up in november biden
needs to deliver something to motivate
voters
he needs a win because already to be
quite honest
president biden has not been able to get
his agenda passed with the policing and
reform the george floyd bill he's not
been able to get any agenda passed with
respect to voting rights
the new justice is expected to be
younger and could sit on the court for
decades the senate has promised to take
up biden's nomination quickly
president biden wants a quick
confirmation of his nominee well
democrats still controlled the senate
after congressional elections in
november that's no guarantee republicans
could take control
and block any future biden nomination to
the supreme court
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house